welcome back to pj chain design today
we're gonna talk about how to create the
snow
flex shape and also the stone setting
for this pendant design
are you ready let's get started
we are going to start it at the front
view with a polygon tool
snapping into the center and let's go
ahead to do
exactly the size that you want it so i'm
gonna
make sure the number of the size is
number six and i'm going to go
about this side after we do that i'm
going to snapping into the zero again
draw a straight line here and snapping
into the end point here and snapping
into the midpoint here that's going to
help me
to make it really symmetrical and then
we are going to have
this one to mirror within this midpoint
mirror to the other side and once we do
that let's go ahead to trim each other
all right
and don't forget to join them once you
trim it
all right so now we have this piece over
here
we're simply just going to mirror to the
other side
and pick up both of them and join
together so now this is
one of the elements simply what we're
going to do is we're going to polar
array but
let me go ahead to
offset this guy for whatever thicknesses
that you want i'm going to set it up for
1.5 millimeter and then offset the
curve then we'll have a curve inside of
it
equally distant to the h so let me
turn this one and this one highly
temporary so it's
easier for you to see we are going to
use the
polar array and snapping into the
endpoint here of course number will be
six of them and then we'll get something
like this
now i'm gonna pick up all the outside
one and instead of trimming each other
i'm going to use the
command curve bowling and it will ask
you
which one you wanted to keep and i'm
going to pick up this one
and delete the input so it will clean up
all the center for me automatically
so we're gonna pick up this one again
coming into the top view and decided how
thick we want to have this one let's
extruded the curve and straight
i'm going to make sure the both sides is
on and i'm going to
type it 1.2 so i'm going to end up with
the 2.4 millimeter for the thickness
once we have that we can go ahead to
giving a fitted edges
so it will look nicer let's try a 0.2
there and we're going to select every
single edges now it's the stone setting
part
i have a diamond video to show you how
to make the diamond i'm going to put the
link on the right top corner
or if you like to download the stone to
use on this tutorial you are welcome
to do so and the link is at the
description below
once we bring this stone in i'm going to
actually setting one in the middle and a
few other
on the side so i'm going to making a
copy over here let's take a look on the
front view
so once i have a stone here i want to
make sure the stone is
in right in the center and scale it down
to
the proper size my goal is putting one
prong here and one prong here so let's
take a look on the side view
we want a stone to be the girdle to
be aligned with the surface at the front
and i'm going to simply just draw a line
roughly about this going about
here and then uh with this one simply
we're just going to pipe it first and
i'm thinking about
this size here okay and
it is too long that's fine we just need
to make sure that we have enough we can
trim it off later
this is important here you do not want
to have the
prong is too cutting too much inside of
the stone which probably will be super
weak so we need to make sure it's
roughly about 20
20 to 30 percent where the prong size is
it's for um where the position is going
to be
and once we have that um you can make
them bigger if you want to
um but you do not want to get it way too
small
let's go ahead to mirror to the other
side and using
the stone center of the stone as our
um mirror point all right the stone
need to be sitting on something so i'm
going to also
hiding this one and we are going to
and we are going to draw a circle and
snapping right here
about any of any of this size is fine
this is just a rail
and then we're gonna coming over to the
side
i'm going to draw a rectangle
and roughly about this size here and we
can make it longer we can always trim it
later that's fine
and let's go ahead to draw something
like this
so let me move it somewhere about here
as you can see this is where the
position
is and i'm going to use the command
for revolve and going to snapping into
the center over here bringing down to
my right view and want to revolve 360
degree
and then that's how we get this one and
if this is
too big over there you can always scale
it down but you want to make sure that
this full point is touching the wall of
our
snowflake and so that way it will have a
better casting that's bringing back
to the shape that we were doing earlier
and take a look and see if that is what
you like i may need to move
this down just a little bit so i will
see my stone better okay so if
everything look good to you just go
ahead to
bowling unit this one and we also wanted
to
creating a block and moving this block
down and get it a little bit shorter
just a little bit shorter
uh then there's no flag there and let's
do the bowling difference
this one out of this one so that is
one there and we can simply pick up this
one and this one
and we can do polar array snapping into
the center
one or six of them and they will fit it
in there
now i also wanted to bring one up
about here and this one i'm going to
rotate it for 30 degree here and making
a copy
so then i will have that one this one i
can did it
okay so again we are going to pick up
this one and we're gonna use the polar
array
snapping into the center for six of them
and that's how we get this one
the one in the middle actually we'll
need to cut the opening
it's because having a hole behind the
stone is always gonna
going to make the stone look brighter
and so i have this cylinder here we're
gonna do
uh bowling different which is the shape
of a snowflakes
difference out from that cylinder so we
have something like that
and i can simply just making a quick
prong let me use
this again and we are going to
pipe it with almost the same size
and with this prime i simply just wanted
to move it down
and to make a better arrangement i
actually want this prawn
to uh it 30 degree
there and then you can take a look if
that is looking nice over there
and again we don't want it to cut it too
much
over here and then if that look okay
let's go ahead to
polar array with the same number for
number six
and 360 degree and that's how we get
that one
and apparently the prong is a little bit
too long so i'm going to
simply just draw whatever box there
and then moving this box about here
i'm going to pick up all the prong in
the center so we're going to pick up
those and different spawn difference out
from the block
so that's what we get it there for the
rest of it we just need to make a bell
and with the jump ring place in the
right place maybe a little bit lower
so that can be a pendant or for the
charm
please let me know what do you think
about the tutorial leave the comment
below
and let me know if you have any other
question thank you for watching
i'll see you next
[Music]
so